CBS News has learned that the four men
with alleged ties to the kidnapping of
an American tourists on safari in Africa
are under arrest this morning Kimberly
sue Endicott and her guide were released
five days after the gunmen inducted them
abducted them rather inside a national
park in Uganda Endicott arrived at the
US Embassy in Uganda yesterday and is
now on her way home Deborah Patterson
Entebbe Uganda with new details of this
ordeal Deborah good morning to you
good morning this Ugandan safari
adventure was always high on Kimberly su
Endicott's bucket list we're told she
never imagined though it would turn into
such a nightmare
sources have told CBS News that Endicott
and her guide were forced to walk across
the border from Uganda into the
Democratic Republic of Congo where they
spent most of the five days of their
captivity the pair traveled long
distances on foot and slept out in the
open bush at night using a mattress and
a sheet Endicott's emotional state was
up and down but probably at its lowest
when they realized they'd crossed the
border into the DRC the four suspects
arrested in connection with the
kidnapping are being interrogated by
police it's understood they are illegal
fish traders and ivory smugglers Ugandan
police tracked him down with the
assistance of as many as 19 FBI agents
who provided surveillance equipment CBS
News has learned that the kidnap was
made almost nothing from the ransom paid
for Endicott's release despite their
demand for half a million dollars Norah
all right Thank You Deborah pata in
Uganda